hello there Ragnarok is here and you're
probably about to play through the final
part of kratos's Journey to the Norse
realm so let's go through the story of
2018's God of War to prepare you I'll
link a video breaking down the God of
Wars time in the Greek pantheon as today
this video is solely dedicated to the
2018 game let's do this
years have passed since we last saw the
Spartan warrior Kratos who now lives the
life of a mortal man in midgard with his
wife Faye and son atreus we never
actually meet Faye as she has died
recently and Kratos is tasked with
finding trees for her funeral pyre Fey
marks the trees she wanted for her final
farewell and with that comes her final
request she wishes for her Ashes to be
scattered at the highest point in the
land as her Embers call an unexpected
visitor arrives a stranger wanting
answers in the name of Odin long story
short an epic battle breaks out and
Kratos is Victorious The Stranger is
banished
banished still in mourning Father and
Son collect face ashes and the adventure
begins to find the highest peak in the
nine Realms kratel struggles to interact
with his son and its clear Fey was the
more involved parent in atreus's
upbringing it is revealed that Kratos
never told his new family about his past
neither of them knowing that he was not
a mere mortal he was a God and the son
of Zeus it also appears that Faye hid
secrets too as the trees she selected
for her funeral were part of a magic
spell which hid her family from prying
eyes in the Norse realm and by cutting
down that tree Kratos has broken that
spell dad and boy attempt to bond but
atreus's sickness prevents much of it an
illness that appears when he's angry or
rageful eventually the pair bond via
hunting including pursuing this ball as
target practice and lunch that ball
happens to be a friend of the witch in
the woods another God hiding in the
wilderness with her help the bar is
saved and freyja somehow agrees to help
the duo in their Quest as she misses her
own son so much Kratos and atreyas begin
to find more hell walkers in the world
beings that should be locked in hell are
somehow walking among the living by the
way hell or hellheim in nor Smith is
super cold and icy unlike the fiery hell
you may be thinking about the duo grab a
boat and travel to the Lake of the nine
the lake is now desolate with a single
statue above water level atreus reads
the text upon it sacrifice your arms to
the center of the water we must
sacrifice our arms to the lake so Kratos
Yates Leviathan into the water evoid out
pops jorman Gander I'll I'll stick to
saying it in my own accent yomunganda is
the world serpent so big he can wrap
around the entire world and eat his own
tail if he so chooses there's a prophecy
in this land that Thor and yomunganda
are destined to kill each other when
Ragnarok begins I'm forward to that the
Lake's water level has lowered now since
the world serpent has moved and dad and
boy continue adventuring by this time we
have met two dwarf blacksmiths sindri
and Brock who are responsible for
creating the Leviathan ax we wield each
continue to upgrade it for Kratos in
honor of its true owner Faye who gave
the extra Kratos the dwarfs currently
hate each other and pop up throughout
the whole game thanks to Dwarven magic
that can render them invisible to
everyone well except dragons we'll get
to that Kratos and atreus look to be
closing in on the highest point in the
nine Realms but a deadly fog blocks
their path the black breath out of
nowhere freyja appears and tells them
they'll need the light of Alpine to go
any further this lets us see idrisil the
only way to move between the nine Realms
and to use it they will need a bifrost
containing that light luckily Freya can
get us to Alpine yet she cannot go there
herself she is trapped in midgard for
now we don't know why so the father-son
combo fight their way to the light they
need to capture while trying
unsuccessfully to stay out of the war
between the light Elves and the dark
elves when they finally find the light
source as instructed Kratos walks into
it and is met with the voice of Faye his
wife he is gone for mere moment but when
he's finally pulled back out of the
light by his son it seems he's been gone
hours if not days at treyar stood guard
and took out hundreds of dark elves
protecting his father it's time to go
back to idrasil and accidentally Kratos
lets the light elves back in control of
the Alpine light it'll be okay won't it
the leader of the Dark Elves attacked
Our Heroes and doesn't stand a chance
his final words are ominous
again
you're up a grave mistake we shouldn't
have let those light elves back in but
without to care in the world great ocean
boy leave alfheim back to the climb to
the highest point in the realm they go
dispelling the black breath that won't
stop them with their shiny Newby thrust
and for a few moments there father and
son are getting along Kratos is starting
to show some emotion towards him leading
to this scene where atreus lights a sky
lantern in his mother's memory after
lots of fighting including a Face-Off
with a freaking Dragon they reach the
summit saving sindri from certain death
to thank them he gives them new arrows
bright green and made of mistletoe very
cool a small moment with huge
ramifications happened next atreus's
quiver strap breaks and Kratos repairs
it using one of those mistletoe
arrowheads remember that it's important
at the very peak of the climb the
stranger that visited kratos's home is
heard interrogating a tree alongside two
more people once they leave we meet
Mamiya ah the very topic of conversation
tattooed man traveling with a child a
prisoner inside a tree destined to live
forever trapped here Odin imprisoned
Mamiya here as he was suspected to be an
ally of the yotan aka the Giants a race
of people that can grow extremely tall
it's said some yotan can see into the
future call it prophecy call it
foresight all we know for sure is Odin
wanted for himself after the yotenheim
Gateway vanished from the world tree's
reach Odin took no chances and
imprisoned Mamiya in an unbreakable tree
and took out one of his All-Seeing eyes
for good measure too Mamiya has bad news
for us too this is not the highest point
in the nine Realms the place we were
gonna scatter phase ashes in actuality
it's in yotenheim and we just found out
that there's no way to get there bummer
on the plus side Mamiya knows a secret
way to jotenheim but he must come with
us to show us long story short Kratos
lobs off mamiya's head and takes it to
freyja to be reanimated and now Kratos
has the coolest appearing in the nine
Realms whilst visiting the witch in the
woods she takes away our mistletoe
arrows and burns them freyja then makes
atreus promise to destroy all mistletoe
he sees in future he reluctantly agrees
when Mamiya is reanimated Freya can't
resist spitting in his face and this is
the cue for Mamiya to reveal her secret
freyja is the wife of Odin another God
and as we all know Kratos hates Gods but
freyja also hates Odin almost as much as
Kratos but for there to be peace between
the Asia and the Vania she agreed to Wed
eventually she taught Odin her people's
magic and he used it to imprison her in
midgard Forever that's why she was
ejected from alfheim earlier on Odin is
a sneaky booger Mamiya joins The
ladslad's Lads tour and tells stories on
the boat which leads to the moment where
he speaks to yorman Gander in his native
tongue and FYI the giant serpent is a
yotum he's one of the Giants himself
literally this time Mamiya talks of the
war between yorman Ganda and the god of
thunder and to make that more visual the
world serpent eats the statue of Thor
nearby next the world serpent physically
moved the bridge to show the trio where
they need to go to next which is to get
a piece of a Dizzle which is currently
embedded in a dead Frost giant head put
there by Thor himself they get it of
course out of nowhere the two men seen
at mamiya's tree are revealed magni and
Modi the sons of Thor an inevitable
battle begins atreus is wound up to a
crazy level then he has a complete loss
of self-control leading to him
collapsing luckily by this point one
brother has run away and the other one
has an ax at his face R.I.P magni Modi
returns to finish the fight Golding
atreyus with your mom jokes until the
little guy triggers his own Spartan rage
just like his dad but unlike his dad
atreyus cannot handle it and passes out
Modi is beaten again and runs away again
Kratos takes the unconscious body of
atreus back to freyja his desire to help
his son outweighing his hatred of all
gods she tells Kratos to go to hellheim
literally hell to bring back the heart
of the bridge keeper he agrees but
Leviathan won't work in hell he needs a
fire that burns like no other defend
Adventure into the frozen hell of
nosmith Kratos travels home and we see
he has kept the blades of chaos all this
time bestowed on him by Ares himself by
returning to his past Kratos is visited
by Athena the goddess who once used him
for her bidding you will always be
he must save his son and travels to
helheim Kratos defeats all that's done
in his way and attempts to escape
hellheim as quickly as possible as
visions of his life are constantly
forced upon him a form of torture down
here Kratos sees the father he once
killed my father your father was this
but with the Heart In Hand he returns to
Freya and his son leaving hell behind
back in midgard atreus is cured hooray
saved from that mysterious illness it's
now clear atreus is subconsciously
fighting his true nature as a God as
he's always been told he's just a mere
mortal to truly remove this illness
Kratos must be honest with his son
Kratos finally comes clean
I'm a God boy
from another land far from here when I
came to these Shores I chose to live as
a man but the truth is
I was born a god
and so were you both father and son are
gods and the boy is delighted his
demeanor changes from this point the
fear of mortality is removed and atreus
suddenly thinks he is the superior to
everyone around him even his father
honestly he becomes such a turd it was
painful playing through this section
he's so cruel to the dwarves he
belittles his own mother what a little
[ __ ] the trio visit the Temple of Tia
that's the Norse God of War by the way
but unlike Kratos this God of War was
more interested in protecting people and
pursuing peace and solutions before War
completely the opposite of kratos's
version of God of War peace was never an
option in the old days of Kratos after a
ton of puzzles and fights we get the
object we came for a black Rune which
combined with the Chisel from earlier
will give us access to yotenheim huzzah
off to the Gateway at the top of midgard
we go again on Route Modi appears one
more time this time he's beaten and
bruised within an inch of his life his
own father did it Thor claims that Modi
is responsible for magnese death Modi is
little threat to Our Heroes yet atreya
still full of himself after learning
he's a God against his father's orders
kills Modi knife to the neck followed by
a gate Kratos and atreus's relationship
is at an all-time low but they continue
on the path to jotenheim and as they are
about to pass through
returns yet we now know more about him
balda is the son of Odin and the brother
of Thor destined to live forever thanks
to an unbreakable spell which makes him
invulnerable to attacks yet this is a
curse too as it removed his ability to
feel anything at all warmth touch snow
arrows he feels nothing nothing affects
him which sent him down a hundred year
journey of anger and hatred during the
fight atreus who is now one of the most
arrogant people you will ever meet
openly shoots his own father with an
arrow and ridicules his dad when he
clumsily breaks the door to jotenheim
during the fight eventually this
arrogant was his undoing as balder grabs
him and attempts to escape back to
Asgard with this offering to Odin
instead Kratos knocks them all into hell
hell Heim for everyone hell continues to
torture all its inhabitants with visions
of their worst moments showing atreyus
the moment he killed Modi he seems to be
the kick up the butt he needed and he
sees the error of his way ways and
atreus slowly reverts back to being a
good kid well done bro elsewhere balda
is being shown moments of his life too
nobody is safe here in this moment we
see Boulder's mother who is none other
than Freya the witch in the woods the
Vania goddess oh and just in case you're
wondering why Mamiya didn't tell them
it's because he was hexed by freyja and
unable to remember that fact finally
kratos's Vision shows him unaliving his
own father Paralyzed by this he needs
atreus to get him back on track which is
lifting a giant ship into the air like a
lantern before jumping off and falling
into one of Odin's secret Chambers here
we discover the final hidden piece of
the puzzle tears I the Norse god of war
was so trusted by the yotam that those
giants gave him the gift of sight and it
so happens Mamiya has that too he
unlocks the hidden scriptures those eyes
allowed the holder to travel to the
realm between Realms there's one issue
though Mamiya is missing an eye and the
dwarves say it's in the thirst statue oh
yeah government Gander ate that statue
earlier so we have to go inside the
world serpent surprisingly the big
wiggly worm is okay with this letting
the trio inside his stomach to find the
eye and now Mamiya has two of them as
they are leaving something attacks
yamanganda leaving him hurt and throwing
out Kratos and atreus who Land by the
frost giant corpse they are joined by
freyja who no longer hides how she gets
around she shapeshifts into animals and
finally Boulder joins them walking out
of the water like 007 himself it was he
who beat The Living Daylights out of the
world serpent so he'd spit them out
Boulder is taken aback by the sight of
his mother after all these years and his
desire to unalive her is almost
uncontrollable instead though he has
another scrap with Kratos this party
walk
vengeance
you will find no peace
I know epic battle number three begins
and this time atreus is in control of
his actions yet Boulder has no issue
punching a child in the chest so hard he
almost stops breathing Kratos Comforts
his son the real Revelation is finally
here the mistletoe arrows Freya burned
were a clue all along the one used to
fix a Tracy's quiver strap had punctured
balder's hand his curse was lifted he
could now feel everything his personal
hell is over yet instead of enjoying the
moment Boulder still fully intends to
take the life of his mother for the
suffering he has endured for lifetimes
Kratos and atreus will not allow this
and epic battle number four takes place
constantly interrupted by Freya who
tries to broke a piece by holding the
fighters in place this fails so she
casually reanimates the frost Giant and
puppets it to break her son and Kratos
apart the fight scene is so epic as
Kratos and atreus fights side by side
for the first time defeat in Boulder
once again but to show the growth of
atreus during the game he calls for his
Barber to stand off
his beautiful father
is unable to walk away and strangles his
own mother who is okay with giving her
life for her son but Kratos doesn't
agree the cycle has to be broken here
balda is dead for real this time feeling
snow on his face for the first and final
time overwhelmed with grief for her son
Freya vows to avenge him and feed your
soul to the vilest filth in hell that is
my promise he saved your life he robbed
me of everything Kratos uses the moment
to come clean with his son admitting to
all the Deeds of his life of War good
and bad and even killing his own father
atreus asks a question which will mean
everything to the next game
son's killing their mothers
their fathers
no
[Music]
finally they opened the door to
yotenheim and fulfill the original
objective of the game to scatter the
ashes of Fae atreus's mother to the
winds at the highest point in the nine
Realms here in the Land of the Giants
yotenheim no living Soul exists only
corpses and dust can be seen atreya
stumbles across a mural on the wall
which depicts everything we've been
through so far from meeting the world
serpent to fighting Boulder and freyja
betrays his mother Faye saw it all and
she is revealed to be one of the Autumn
louthi a standard-sized giant with
foresight she kept her godhood from
Kratos as he thought he did too which
means the day the stranger came to visit
he was actually looking for Fey and not
Kratos as atreus walks away Kratos sees
something that hasn't happened yet his
own death dying in the arms of atreus as
some sort of serpent emerges Kratos and
atreus fulfill their vow and FaZe ashes
are scattered to the wind Kratos has
finally let go of his bind son now knows
all his Secrets he doesn't need to hide
anymore but wait there is another
bombshell atreus finds out he was named
after a Spartan warrior Kratos admired
yet Faye had another name for him
Petraeus is known to the Giants as Loki
the Giants called me
Loki the tricks to God from myth the two
finally go home for some well-deserved
rest and relaxation yet atreyus or
should I say Loki has another vision
foreign
[Music]
Ragnarok is here